donc vous dites est le fils de julien
lepers ça je ne le perd c'est
l'animateur bien sûr de questions pour
un champion comment vous avez appris que
julie lepers un julien lepers
[Rires]
existent mais elles sont très dissipée
l'excusé d'ericsson alors quand j'étais
petit de la bouche de ma mère bien sûr
bien sûr ouais comme quand ils se
rencontrent et ben ma mère travaillé
chez maniatis à l'époque elle jean-marc
je sais pas chez les coiffeurs voilà
voilà c'est ça elle faisait elle est
esthéticienne d'accord donc elle quoi
faire un petit enfin voilà s'occuper un
peu de tout le monde et qui sont connues
elles veulent elles voyez herbert
léonard à l'époque donc ils sortaient
ensemble elles sortaient qu'à moi ils
s'accordent c'est un ami juste herbert
léonard bah je sais pas si bonnes
connaissances je rappelle que julien
lepers écrite
et
donc il se sent certainement rencontré
par le biais de d'herbert et puis ils se
sont revus quand même assez longuement
pendant deux ans ouais donc ma mère
décrit bien dans l'interview c'était et
c'est donc à la suite de ça arrivait à
mes 13 14 ans j'ai voulu le voir j'ai
voulu en savoir plus en décalage de
l'ogec j'ai 34 ans d'accord et donc vous
avez voulu le voir l'âge de 13 14 ans
normale et ben au bout d'un moment on se
pose des questions on veut savoir qui on
est d'où on vient et puis voilà donc
j'ai écrit cette lettre avec tous les
détails et il est venu un jour chez moi
en fait sens comme ça de son propre chef
et puis donc on a discuté et il a décidé
de me prendre j'ai été en normandie chez
lui et puis par la suite là bas ça c'est
un petit peu mal passé il a coupé les
pôles en fait d'accord mais au départ il
a voulu quand même il a fait mais de la
marge quand même devenu l'affairé qu'il
est venu de vous amener en normandie sur
wii c'est une année illzach où lui vous
étiez son fils vous êtes son fils
apparemment quand quand il est venu
c'est qu'ils se posent des questions
bien sûr que je dis quoi il vous a dit
oui je sais que tu es mon fils ou bien
non au début il avait pas de tout ça
donc il est venu
il n'a pas vraiment posé ces questions
il a demandé de vous lui vous connaître
voilà ce que je faisais où j'avais
grandi et c'est ça lui poser un peu un
problème mais le mon beau père qui était
là à l'époque a réussi à bien discuter
avec lui voilà il a eu un peu confiance
en mon beau-père et il m'a pris et puis
vous êtes parti en normandie avec lui et
que vous êtes resté combien de temps je
suis restée je devais rester une semaine
je suis resté cinq jours le cinquième
jour je suis parti en fait pourquoi vous
êtes vous entendiez pas non en fait ça
se passait très bien mais il avait caché
un mât demi soeur à lorraine que j'étais
peut-être son frère d'accord donc moi je
suis arrivé quand on est descendu il a
fallu que je mente que je joue je joue
un rôle donc c'était un peu compliqué et
puis c'était pesant puisque ben à
l'époque elle était petite et elle
trouvait qu'on se ressemblaient beaucoup
donc elle pose énormément de questions
et ça s'est mal passé un jour parce que
je lui ai demandé dans la voiture
quelque chose et puis je la prépare son
bac en disant papa en fait c'est ça et
il l'a mal pris et donc moi je me suis
braquée je suis rentré et puis comme un
enfant j'étais à fond maintenant c'est à
nous et à 20 ans il était way à 20 ans
j'avais plein temps et depuis voulait
plus jamais non plus une fois c'est sur
le quai de la gare
septimaniens dit je veux plus avoir de
contact avec toi et voilà je vous a fait
mal forcément vous dire sur bon après
j'ai grandi non mais c'est sur mais bon
quand même plus où me disais que ça se
passait très bien que vous aviez ou à la
baisse n'est pas de problème c'est
franchement c'était vous étiez heureux
de retrouver ben j'étais heureux de
rencontrer et j'espérais aussi en savoir
un peu plus sur moi même vous avez vous
avez fait des tests ne m'en fais des
thèses et fait des tests pour savoir si
vous étiez vraiment le fils de oui oui
on a fait des tests mais on a eu trois
le premier était à 81 18 9 ou quelque
chose comme ça face était extrêmement
probant mais il a demandé une
contre-expertise c'est descendu ensuite
entre 60 et 70 et puis non on à la
demande est une autre et c'est descendu
à 55 donc comprends pas trop pourquoi
mais j'ai voulu aller rechercher les
premières cartes mères alice sûr que
c'est jeu
yanis qui dit regardez maintenant ma
mère je vais poser beaucoup de fois la
question quand j'étais petit parce que
c'est quand même gros mais bon elle et
elle sait ce qu'elle fait elle sait ce
qu'elle a fait quoi et aujourd'hui ça y
est vous c derrière vous avez en de
vivre votre vie vous n'avez pas envie de
revenir là dessus si j'aimerais savoir
d'où je viens et savoir si j'ai vraiment
envie d'être sûr ici c'est sûr vous avez
envie de le revoir oui et puis aussi
j'ai une demi soeur avec qui j'ai encore
des contacts plus ou moins donc on a
failli faire les tests de notre côté
mais apparemment elle a dû lui dire
certainement par respect pour lui et ça
lui a pas plu du tout donc ça s'est pas
fait mais on allait faire ça de notre
côté d'accord donc
voila moi j'aimerais si si possible
essayez dre de clarifier tout ça et si
j'ai seulement occupés et si j'ai des
grands parents etc etc